[Music]
hi guys it's quinn if you enjoy my
videos please help out by clicking the
like button it's the only way that the
youtube algorithm really takes notice of
me
also this video will have some spoilers
for the dune book sequels
human beings like all other life on this
planet
are mortal
and ever since the ancient world we have
attempted to find ways to extend our
lives
alchemy is a branch of philosophy
created in the ancient world
those who called themselves alchemist
attempted to perfect and purify certain
elements
many believed that through perfection of
the human soul and body one could create
the ultimate work of alchemy
this idea is often thought of today as
the creation of the philosopher's stone
the philosopher's stone would be able to
heal any illness
turn any metal into gold and most
importantly grant immortality
though people have been trying to figure
out how to create the philosopher's
stone since 300 ce
no one has ever accomplished this
in the third book in the dune series
children of dune the lady jessica
atreides returns to the planet arrakis
after being gone for two decades
and the time since she was last on
arrakis much has changed
the former emperor of the imperium
shaddam iv is dead and house atreides
rules the human universe from the planet
arrakis
jessica's daughter aaliyah now sits the
throne as regent until paul's pre-born
twins lato and genima come of age
the princess ireland paul's wife acts as
protector to his children
when jessica arrives on araka she
immediately notices that both the
princess ireland and her daughter aliyah
are using forbidden bini jesuit
techniques in order to slow their aging
and god forfinned there stood the
princess iralon hiding her savagery in
that seductive body with its cap of
golden hair exposed by a vagrant breeze
irlan seemed not to have aged today it
was an affront and there at the point of
the wedge was aliyah her features
impudently youthful her eyes staring
upward into the hatchway's shadows
any reverent mother of the benny jesuit
could potentially slow their aging
process down to a near halt
this is due to the bini jesuit ability
to control their internal body chemistry
down to a molecular level
but the sisterhood had determined that
this was the wrong path
the human universe ran on spice
the spice heightened awareness and could
more than double the human lifespan
spice was the most valued commodity in
the universe
the sisterhood believed that if they
allowed themselves to halt their own
aging that eventually others in the
human universe would notice the
accumulation of immortal bini jesuit
women
and then turn upon the sisterhood for
this reason reverend mothers allowed
themselves to age naturally only using
spice melange to extend their lives
many reverend mothers could choose that
course or try it the manipulation of
internal chemistry was available to
initiates of the sisterhood
but if one did it sooner or later all
would try it there could be no
concealing such an accumulation of
ageless women they knew for a certainty
that this course would lead them to
destruction
short-lived humanity would turn upon
them no it was unthinkable
the benny jesuit however understood the
value of certain individuals with every
death potentially a valuable member of
the sisterhood would be lost
so the benny jesuit developed a way to
copy each other's memories
they called it sharing in a way they had
developed their own unique form of
immortality
imminent threat of death was recognized
sharing necessary transformation of a
reverend mother into sets of memories
passed around at perilous cost among the
sisters no longer carried a mysterious
aura for her but merbella still was awed
by the responsibility the courage of
rebecca and lucilla demanded admiration
the benny jesuit sisterhood was led by
an all-powerful reverend mother
when it came time to choose a new one
her memories are shared with her
successor
that way all of the valuable knowledge
that she gathered during her lifetime
will be preserved
the process of sharing often could cause
powerful changes in the personalities of
the reverend mothers who shared memories
there is also however an exception to
the benny jesuit rule against using bini
jesuit internal chemistry control
techniques to slow aging
during the time of the god emperor later
the second spice production ceased due
to the disappearance of the desert and
the death of the arrakis sandworms
the god emperor gave out rations to
groups within the imperium where he saw
fit
since spice was no longer readily
available to the mini jesuit they laxed
on the rule against using these
techniques
lato lifted his attention to the
attendance waiting where the mini jesuit
entourage had first stopped
the acolytes wore hoodless black gowns
he saw tiny clues two forbidden rituals
about them an amulet a small trinket a
colorful corner of a kerchief so
arranged that more color might be
flashed carefully
lato knew that the reverend mothers
allowed this because they no longer
could share the spice as they once had
if anything this illustrates one of the
main strengths of the benny jesuit
sisterhood
their pragmatism
their ability to adapt and alter their
behavior in order to survive and the
fact that benny jesuit individuals for
thousands of years resisted allowing
themselves to halt their aging when they
easily could have is a testament to the
sisterhood's dedication to their cause
[Music]
you